hello ladies welcome to the Boogie bus
where we're banging in the back to the
beat of our butts hello everybody my
name is markiplier and welcome back to
turbo dismount there was another update
where they added to entirely new
vehicles with a lot of new poses and I
know that you guys are gonna love it so
let's get into it we should be good why
was I split in half
I just want people to appreciate this
for what it is go my little friend go
shake the booty and I really saw okay
get a little bit of it a little bit of
hesitation I can see why thank you for
the crowd
that is the sexiest dance I've ever seen
me do in my life shame
Jake me Jake I know you had such big
jugs does anybody want to get in the
back of the bus with me anybody oh I get
the pelvic okay my pelvis has been
inserted into the vehicle oh my god my
friend oh is that the Superman thrusting
action oh god you got really tanky there
for a second look there's your half oh
hi hi back there you're bouncing away
from me but that's okay you have fun
over there can we just appreciate the
artistic nature of this freaking boogie
bus right here
oh yeah really feel it
feel the beat hog hope you didn't feel
that god that is so cool
oh my god oh god I like how my screams
of joy turned to screams of agony very
quickly alright let's go for it I don't
care Oh obviously the best pose possible
to confront whatever the hell is going
on over here alright just go man I got
nothing clever to say I think your pose
speaks for itself never mind
well my computer's lagging is that good
alright just crammed in there we got a
few more spots uptown just crammed in
keep going in little more down low room
squeeze it and make friends you're
comfortable all right so this is the
other vehicle that was added called the
boss throne which might actually be in
reference to jacksepticeye who plays
this game a lot more than okay excuse me
I was trying to make a speech about Jack
anyway he says like a boss a lot hahaha
this may just be the most boring map
I've ever seen in my life unless this
does something absolutely amazing I'm
going to be very disappointed
Wow
[Applause]
hey could you hit me really hard in the
face I'd really appreciate my legs I
really need to find a quicker way into
death just ROI yourself Oh God
no hi this is good I like the
spread-eagle aspect of it this way
you'll hit your head first and you died
my face I like how the head is just
completely detached from the body it's
kind of anticipating what's gonna happen
to you in a few seconds okay all you
need to do is okay you already screwed
it up
just do it tuck into double over are you
even listening to what I say to the
future I wonder what's gonna happen now
[Applause]
just keep it together kind of knows that
that was horribly wrong but at least
you're okay right
I sure hope my pelvic thrust blocked me
from this a little bit I feel like I
should warn you about something
something strange that's coming up just
um dude I can't even promise you're
gonna get over that ramp oh you did its
glory two hours to stalk sky all right
if the boss throne is not gonna make it
out there the boogie bus sure as hell
oh no oh come on I miss em please thank
you
now die die a horrible death okay come
on can you land the mines at least yeah
oh I'm so upset with you right now you
don't look at me like that don't shake
your body at me
honestly all come on I don't care how
cool you think you are my token bird is
okay great could you please just make it
through one that's all I ask
just all please please no black boss
well I can't exactly say this is gonna
go well for you Oh maybe if you talk
nicely to them oh I really don't have
any advice at all for your friends maybe
because you're in the back of the buses
oh okay never mind if I'm on top of it I
can't die right right oh no no no all
right so that was the latest update to
turbo dismount I love the fact that
they're adding new vehicles to the game
all the time and I might just make an
episode every time they make an update
to the game but either way I hope you
guys enjoyed this video if you did
please consider clicking that like
button down below it really does help me
out thank you again everybody for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video
[Music]
[Laughter]